[Applause]
the topic that we will explore today is
in many ways one of trying to figure out
some of the deepest implications of what
it means to be a human being when we
first formed the ocf Orthodox chisan
Fellowship last year one of the
discussion one of the very first
discussions we had at our uh weekly
meeting was one that dealt with how we
see ourselves today how we in our
society and especially as students have
lost something very sacred about our
in many currents of thought and most
certainly in our hyper rationalized
deconstructed postmodern world one loses
sight of the meaning of not only those
things which are external to us but in
the process we fail to understand the
very core of our being many of you will
know that recently uh Dr Jordan Peterson
has faced an immense set of controversy
precisely for questioning the dogmas of
our age and yet he has also stressed the
importance of the Divine individual and
the Christian concept of the logos which
I will allow our speakers to elaborate
upon today a dear friend had told me
once that what fundamentally divides
Orthodoxy from any other kind of
ideology is precisely this the Dignity
of the Divine individual and what this
means for us as spiritual and physical
beings and so I'm immensely excited to
hear what our panelists have to say
tonight and so I'd like to introduce
each of our panelists starting with
father Theodore
kopos uh who is a junct faculty at the
Orthodox School of Theology at Trinity
College uh last semester he taught a
course on the human person in Orthodox
Theology and Orthodox tradition and in
many ways this is something that touches
upon or introduces the very core of
what's being discussed today what is the
individual what does it mean to be human
H and he is also quite a positive
Presence at our Orthodox Christian
fellowship and we certainly look forward
to hearing his perspectives tonight
Jonathan Pou is a very well-known icon
Carver from Quebec as well as an editor
for the Orthodox Arts Journal many of us
were familiar with Jonathan and his work
prior to this and so it's a great
pleasure to have him here tonight and
indeed it is it's entirely appropriate
just this past Sunday the Orthodox
Church celebrated in the spirit of unity
uh the Sunday of Orthodoxy the
celebration of our triumph over
iconoclasm the tradition of icon graphy
in the Orthodox tradition is one of deep
Theology and I'm very pleased that an
expert on the matter is with us here
today and many of you may be interested
to hear Jonathan's online discussion
with Dr Peterson uh the most recent one
being concerned with one of the most
controversial political symbols of this
day the metaphysics of
Pepe Dr Jordan B Peterson is a professor
of psychology here at the University of
Toronto and I think it goes without
saying that the activism of Dr Peterson
has inspired ins spired many in the room
today many who would have previously
perhaps not even considered looking into
the type of Concepts which are going to
be discussed
today myself and many others have been
deeply moved by not only Dr Peterson's
Insight on matters of a political nature
but also in his Insight in human nature
the title of this discussion was
influenced by Dr Peterson's usage of the
concept of the Christian concept of
logos and what that means for us as
individuals I'd like to thank Dr
Peterson for joining us and we are
greatly looking forward to hearing more
of your Insight on this matter last but
not least father Jeffrey ready who is
the co-director of the Orthodox School
of Theology uh the chaplain of our
Orthodox Christian fellowship and the
parish priest at the holy Mar Bears
Orthodox Mission uh located at Trinity
Chapel from the very creation of our ocf
last year father Jeffrey has
continuously blown our minds and
enhanced our understanding not only of
our Orthodox spiritual life but of
ourselves as human beings apart from his
remarkable pastoral qualities his wealth
of knowledge and perspective has made it
only natural that we would offer his
perspective on this panel tonight I'd
like to thank Father Jeffrey for his
work and greatly look forward to hearing
his perspectives tonight so the format
for the discussion today will be
basically that each of our panelists
will speak for for a time and this will
be followed by a question and answer
period each of you will have received a
um and each row has about two pens so
for the duration of the discussion you
can write down your questions and pass
them up at the front and then we'll try
to well get through as many of them as
possible by the end of the
night and with that I'd like to welcome
father Theodore peros to the podium to
begin our discussion thank
[Applause]
you
okay so there's not going to be any
mindblowing okay let's reserve for
father Jeffrey thank you to the ocf at
UFT uh for asking me to come and to be
up here on the stage with people that I
kind of feel I feel out of outclass
definitely but um I appreciate the
invitation uh so I was told to speak for
like 10 to 15 minutes about uh what it
means to be a human person in the
Orthodox radition so I don't know how
POS possible that is um
but Vlad just mentioned that uh in the
past uh two days on Sunday we celebrated
in the Orthodox tradition the Sunday of
Orthodoxy which is the first Sunday in
Lent uh for those of you who don't know
what that is or don't know what we
celebrate on that day we celebrate the
return of the Holy icons into the church
now a lot of people who've been to
Orthodox Churches know that the church
is full of icons and they Wonder well
when was there a return and why was
there a return considering you know to
we ever not have them of course
Christians have had images in their
churches and in their places of worship
in the very beginning but there was a
time that um there was an oppression of
uh the idea of using images as uh and it
was considered to be idolatry within the
church and there was a faction uh within
the church that um that fought against
this and for almost 100 years uh icons
were uh burned destroyed uh and taken
out of churches and it was only with the
seventh ecumenical council uh that they
were returned of course why do we
celebrate this on Sunday of Orthodoxy
and why do we call it Sunday of
Orthodoxy is because those who were the
proponents of icons and of course all
modern Orthodox Christians today knew
that the attack on the depiction of
Christ was an attack on the Incarnation
itself on the idea that Christ is an
actual human being he actually existed
actually lived and lives he was an
actual historical figure who lived at a
certain time and not a figment of our
imagination as some people today would
say and uh this means that when we speak
about God and when we speak about the
Trinity when we speak about the second
person of the Trinity who's the son the
logos um as we were speaking about
tonight uh we are speaking about a very
specific
person and uh that is in contrast to
many of the discussions that we see
today both in the public forum online uh
that's supposedly like this uh where we
where many people would like to think of
God as an abstract for orthodox
Christians and I would say for you know
historical ancient Christianity God is
not an abstract rather God is an actual
person there's an objective reality
there Christ is an objective person he
thinks a certain way speaks a certain
way acts a certain way even looked a
certain way and so we can depict him in
icons now the reason why I started with
this and I kind of you know begin uh my
thoughts is uh because there is a little
bit of a
contrast uh between many religions and
Orthodoxy uh this is not this is
generalization uh but as generalizations
go uh in many religions whether they be
Christian or not um the concept of God
or the concept of the Divine usually
centers around the idea of the word of
God or the concept of God made text
there there are usually writings about
this and writings that are usually very
anent they're passed down and the text
is usually what is focused on even
amongst many Christian denominations
it's all about the text however in the
Orthodox tradition it is not about the
word becoming text but rather about the
word becoming flesh becoming a human
being and so our faith is not based on a
text but rather on a deep mystical
experience of the Risen Lord throughout
time now you're going to say well we
read the Bible too right we use the
Bible we venerate the Bible we have it
in very high regard however for ancient
Christianity I love that CU I like Star
Trek
too
um there you go
um when we uh when we speak about uh
Christ and we speak about God we speak
about a living tradition Christ didn't
found uh a book neither did he found a
philosophy but rather he founded a very
real Community a living community and
the Church the last 2,000 years is this
living community that has never stopped
it has never ceased to exist it was
never a time where it did not exist um
we have no beginning we have no reformer
we have no founder uh we have no school
of thought for uh but rather uh we exist
from the very beginning so the reason
why I say this is because our concept of
God and our concept of our relationship
to him is a very intimate one and one
that has been living for the last uh
2,000
years
so going back to the idea of
incarnational Theology and of
icons uh if we are to say that God is
real if he actually exists if we don't
believe in that well then this talk
doesn't really matter but if we believe
that God exists and that God is an
actual person he has a mind his
personality and that Christ is God in
human form then uh the reality is is
that there is an objective reality to
who God is and by that we can say that
there's an objective truth that we can
speak about and there is an objective
good that we can speak about and there
is an objective understanding of the
human being that it is not subjective
but rather
objective and for us as Orthodox
Christians we tend to follow the model
that was coined by St athanasio the
great famous Fourth Century father of
the church and great Theologian who said
that God became man so that we may
become God not that we may become real
Gods but like God so for us the goal of
the Christian life is to emulate Christ
to become Christlike it's not about what
I think of myself it's not about what I
want to be or what I what I would like
to create in my mind of what I would
like to be or what I think I am but
rather that there is Christ and Christ
is the perfect human being and I try to
discover what that is and I know that is
diametrically opposed to the society
that we live in today for the most part
for the most part that we live in a
society that is a society of
subjectivity not objectivity and we live
in a society that when it speaks about
religion it speaks about spirituality
when it speaks about speaks about
theology it usually refers to the
subjective understanding of God the
subjective understanding of the human
person as professor Peterson has been
dealing with in the last few months
um so when we talk about human identity
it is um it is something that is to be
discovered not to be kind of created or
self-created
so you know there's a there's a writing
at a very early second century writing
in the church called the which means the
teaching uh one of the earliest writings
of the church I guess you could say it's
one of the earliest manuals um of how to
be a Christian or the basics of the
Christian faith I guess you could say
and in the it says the first line says
there are two
ways um one of life and one of death and
there's a great difference between the
two this the opening lines and uh and
really when it comes to you know the uh
the understanding of the human person
from an orthodox point of view we would
say the same thing that there are really
two ways to understand there is either
the Revelation from God and how we
emulate that or rather there's the
movement towards the self towards
self-revelation self- understanding and
really uh we would say um self
idolization and uh and
so of course we as human beings are free
to do whatever we want to do um and we
have free will but uh how we use that
and and and what what we do with it and
what we choose to become really uh
depends on where we're looking towards
what we want to do and then and who we
want to be so I would say that the the
modern existential crisis of our time
can really be remedied by the simple
statement that if there is a God there
is a God I'm not
him so the understanding that there's a
God and I'm not that him would mean that
I need to discover who that God is and
what he expects of me and why am I here
and what am I supposed to do with my
life and that's diametrically opposed to
the subjective understanding of that God
is whatever I want him to be or what I
would rather him to be and go from
there so in premodern western
civilization um Society was
predominantely you know a society of
these kind of values these kind of
objective truths uh it was kind of like
the social glue that provided stability
for the family and social institutions
and religion and uh and even business
ethics like people believe that there
was a good there was a truth out there
that we needed to discover there was a
God that we needed to somehow figure out
who that God was um and the humility
that was required to accept that we are
not
Gods uh was what held all that together
the social and psychological fabric of
society so without it and this is where
I think um Professor Peterson would also
agree and has said many times without
this kind of uh understanding of an
objective
reality um there is an endless movement
towards the individual towards
subjectivity towards what is relative
and ultimately towards nihilism because
if there is no objective meaning in life
and there is no objective truth in life
then and everything is whatever I make
it and everybody is right then really
everybody is wrong and then really what
you have to live for there no real
Ultimate meaning in
life and so this is the problem you know
and there's a movement towards the
delusion that everyone is their own God
and everyone is free to create
themselves in their own image and this
breeds endless fragmentation as
Professor Peterson has said uh of both
soall individual truths and also
individual
identities
so
if there is no God as we said this
conversation doesn't really matter
however if there is a God and he is a
personal God as the Christian's claim
then we cannot go on ignoring him
without suffering a serious identity
crisis I believe that this crisis has
arrived and the question is how do we as
Christians continue to see the world uh
see the word of God the Divine logos in
those who refuse to see it in themselves
like how do we speak to that how do we
speak to a world that doesn't even
uh acknowledge that there is such a l
that there is such a of Truth in the
first place this is this is the the
conundrum that we find ourselves in the
difficulty how do we witness to a world
that is not speaking the same language
anymore and I think that is uh something
that uh you know discussions like this
um are are extremely important T of the
first steps because here we are
attempting and I and I applaud the ocf
for doing this attempting to find find
points of
convergence between a Christian
tradition the Orthodox Christian
tradition and also um the secular
approach psychology
sociology history biology places where
these things converge and they tell us
and they preach the same truth and this
is why I was so um enthused about coming
and speaking today because watching a
lot of Professor Peterson's uh
videos online I saw that there are a lot
of points that he makes that not only
are congruent with Orthodox Theology and
Orthodox
anthropology but speak common sense to
the world you know a world that is
completely fragmented a world that is
completely disengaged from the idea that
there can be a truth outside of
ourselves and that there needs to be
some type of seeking some type of
understanding of what that truth may be
the main difference difference between
philosophy and theology I always tell my
students is that philosophy comes from
us it is us trying to understand the
world trying to understand the
metaphysical trying to understand God
trying to understand anything you can
philosophize about anything but the
source is the human being and we have
this wonderful thing called the mind
that is so powerful they can do so many
things but that's philosophy theology
deals with Revelation deals with what
has been revealed from outside the human
being from someone else and that's what
that's what the church has to deal with
that's what the Christian what
Christianity has to deal with the idea
of what what God has revealed in himself
by becoming a real human being becoming
one of us and we can't negate that as
much as we try and uh to do so would
mean to negate an important part of
ourselves because we believe as our
Christians like to say all the time and
as we like to quote Genesis where God
says in the very beginning in Genesis
126 that God makes Man In His Image and
his liken
he gives us this great ability to choose
this great ability to reason and to
figure things out for ourselves and to
decide whether we want to be like him or
whether we want to be more like
something else and so this is the great
dilemma it's not just a theological
dilemma it's not just a spiritual
dilemma but it's an existential dilemma
and it's becoming a social dilemma
becoming a political dilemma a
biological dilemma and uh a whole lot of
other
so uh I will end there um I will let uh
my colleague Jonathan take it from here
but I think this is a a general
introduction to at least the way we see
it as Orthodox Christians that God
becomes man so that man can become God
also for the words of apostle Paul there
is not I who live but Christ who lives
with within me and this is our our
ultimate goal thank you very
[Music]
much
other Ted thanks really appreciate I
appreciate being here I appreciate being
in Toronto it's a great town today I
spent uh the day going to the museum and
visiting so I really enjoying the city
I'm going to start with a story um
it's March
2015 and uh I'm driving I'm going to
pick up my children at some friends
house on a Friday night and it's about a
half an hour drive so I'm settling in
and I'm listening to the CBC like I
usually
do but that particular evening the
content is not usually what you get on
the CBC so on the air is this University
of Toronto
professor and what he's saying Rings a
bit off from what I usually hear on that
show and first he's talking about
religion and religious symbolism and
he's doing it in a way let's say he's
doing it without the usual smugness that
we tend to hear when people talk about
religion especially about
Christianity and so here he is talking
about
Christianity but I can tell he's not a
he's not a priest or he's not a a
preacher he's a psychologist he's a
scientist and so as the talk unfolds my
let's say my attention heightens
and after a few minutes just a few
minutes I just I can't believe what I am
hearing as this Propet is going through
stories of Adam and Eve Cain and Abel
jumping to Shakespeare and Milton and gu
and then to Darwin and nii and Yung and
and immediately I see what he's
doing he isn't just trying to
communicate
information he's dancing across this
wide variety of
references because what he wants to do
is he wants to bring out he wants to
trace this underlying
pattern and by doing so he's trying to
awaken something in his listeners he's
not just trying to get them to
understand which is what we usually hear
when we listen to talks no he's trying
to provoke trying to shake people into
experiencing how the world is built with
meaning so he talks about logos which is
truth meaning expressed in word is
search for purpose and logos transform
transforms chaos and potentiality into
being and in opposition to this lies
deceit resentment gradually dismantle
the world and plunge it into ever
growing
chaos I mean of course he's taking this
from the Bible the Book of Genesis from
the gospel of of St John sprinkled with
some
phenomenology but he's very clearly
describing this process at all levels of
reality at the individual the
interpersonal the social political
levels and this interaction between
logos and chaos is the main manner we
could say by which the world is
constantly
sustained so
but this point I am I'm literally
cheering in the car I'm like I'm hitting
my steering
wheel and all I can think is who is this
who is this person talking and why have
I not heard of him before like why is he
not famous I guess we don't ask that
question anymore
right and especially I'm like how does
he know this you see like so the the
attempt to help people see experience
patterns of meaning and religious
symbolism how it connects to all levels
of reality that's what I've been trying
to do for years that's that's been my
goal in life I would say in my carvings
in my articles in my
talks and I would say there's only a
handful of people that I know that I can
relate to at that
level and and it's not that people don't
talk about religious symbolism actually
a lot of people do but usually when you
hear people talk about religious
symbolism at some point you can kind of
picture them in like a tin foil hat and
then you know they they soon
extraterrestrials become part of the of
the discussion um but not this guy he's
just as clear as can be so when I get
home so I reach out to him and I send
him just a little
message uh you know just thanking him
and my expressing my surprise and
linking him to a few few articles I'd
written a few talks I had given you know
that was it I didn't expect I didn't
really expect an
answer but then the next morning I get I
get a message thanking me for my message
and pointing me to uh few lectur that he
had given more specifically on religion
I thought that's pretty cool like that's
that's nice you know this random
quebecer sending messages to him um but
then about about an hour and a half
later I get this
call and I can't do the I can't do the
Kermit
voice
[Applause]
so anyways my memories my memories of
that moment are kind of vague but I
think I probably acted like a
14-year-old meeting Kanye West or
something and now his tone is one of
surprise maybe a bit of confusion and
his basic question and and he's been
asking me this question ever since is
how do you know
this because he'd listened to my talk
and he saw the
relationship between what I was was
saying and what he was saying and the
talk that's ex I had been talking about
how logos organizes potential into
experien
being and so why am I why am I telling
you this I mean first of all I'm telling
you this as an excuse because despite
what Father Ted said here's this Carver
who's standing amongst theologians and
professors so the reason why uh I'm here
is because since then Prof Professor
Peterson and I have developed this this
relationship some of you might have seen
the interviews that we we did together
um but mostly I'm telling you this
because I
know I know that it nears the story of
so many people that are probably here in
this room and and and a lot of the
people that might hear this uh on
YouTube or in the
podcast I know that it mirrors and I
know because dozens of people have told
me of that experience
you know I I have this image I don't
know if people have seen it of Joe Rogan
hearing Dr Peterson talk for the first
time and his jaw
dropping you know and all of a sudden he
sees religion in a completely different
way and I've even received dozens of
message from I would call them inprocess
atheists who say you know my questions
and my thinking have been tilted
slightly in unexpected way
and that experience I think has been
strongest for orthodox Christians like
myself in fact I stop counting the
number of messages I received from
priests asking me so so is Dr Peterson
Orthodox or what and to which I usually
answer no he just likes dosi a
lot and there is even one clergy clergy
man who who who answered to that said oh
yeah he's Orthodox he just doesn't know
it yet
but this correlation has been
persistent so what is this
connection what made the connection
between a traditional Christian like
myself and Dr Peterson so obvious so
immediate and all of this I believe
resolves around the notion of
logos the language of logos is the
underlying language of
Christianity of course we know the the
the first vision of logos in
Christianity comes from the gospel of St
John in the beginning was the logos the
logos was with God and the logos was God
he was in the beginning with God and
through him all things were made without
him nothing was made that has been
made in him was life and that life was
the light of all mankind that light
shines in the darkness and the Darkness
has not overcome
it and this vision of logos would be
continued and developed in the life of
the
church and
especially in the seventh century there
was a saint his name is St Maximus the
Confessor and he really brought this
image of logos I would say to its most
detailed or most elaborate
vision and he did so by taking uh the
notion of logos that was in the new
Testament and he he brought and United
it with the best of what the Western
tradition had already offered he was
able to prune let's say what had come
from philosophy and and and join it with
what the Christian message was so that
it it would attain some clarity and
maybe some
detail and so St Maximus explains that
all things have a logos which are which
is its reason for existing its purpose
and its origin all at once and even its
end so it's all those things at
once and on top of that each thing has a
multitude of Loi that's a word you've
probably never heard before Loi is the
plural of logos and so the the the LOI
they're like the different qualities of
things so the the bless of the blue uh
or the slowness of the
slow and all of these Lois are brought
to together they're woven together we
could say to sustain the existence of
the
world it's really a map of meaning to
use Jordan's
words now these Loi these Essences let's
say of things they don't exist
independently in the same way that
scientists believe things exist out
there uh rather they they exist as they
come together as they are joined
together in our encounter with the world
in a pattern we could
say so we could say for example like
that a sunset has a certain amount of
Loi maybe even an indefinite amount of
characteristics of a sunset but as they
come together to be the experience of
the sunset that's how we experience
reality that's how we we come into
contact with
reality
so all these qualities that say light
color vertical horizontal and the things
the the sun the sky the Earth all of
these things and I could go on there's
an indefinite amount of them what's
important in making that experience Real
is how all those Lois are
united so and in a way they're they're
United within
us and human beings for St Maximus are
seen as as this laboratory where the
whole world Finds Its cohesion and he
expresses it in the sense that the human
being is a
microcosm you could say a condensation
of the
cosmos the place where the cosmos comes
together to make
sense and a good way to see it is is
that human beings actually participate
being in the image of God they
participate in cre ation we see that in
the Book of Genesis the Book of Genesis
God tells Adam to name the
animals and so by his logos
participating in a limited way in the
same manner that the Divine logos was
the source of
everything and the human participation
in this process is not a relativistic
thing uh it's not an individual thing I
mean though it is flexible it's
nonetheless the most objective of
processes as Father Ted
mentioned and so we need to be cautious
though because St Maximus warns us that
it's not just a philosophy or it's not
just a technical description of the
world um this is important because
thinking that religious stories are
exactly the same kind of of encyclopedic
knowledge of modern science is the wrong
way to go with this these logos these
truth about things
are are categories of our engagement
with the world so maybe today we might
call them phenomen phenomenological
categories and so the discovery of truth
of logos it's a personal
Journey it's simultaneously a refinement
of our understanding of the world but at
the same time it becomes a refinement of
our
person so to discover the true nature of
things is to walk on a path of
Truth so food is a wonderful thing and
it's useful for life but gluttony leads
to our destruction wealth is useful to
accomplish important things but avarice
rots the soul so you see it's not just a
description of the world it's a path
that we walk as we discover the
world and so sin in this vision of the
world that horrible world that that
horrible word that no one wants to hear
sin isn't just the breaking of arbitrary
rules but it it's in the misuse of the
world and that misuse of the world ends
up being an untruth ends up being a lie
or or or something that's false
something that separates things from
each
other it's found when things are not
aligned with their
purposes so for example a person uh is
not only a a tool for my own
gratification a person is not just a
tool so that I can advance myself in the
world and if I treat a person
exclusively like that then I will
inevitably sin against that
person I mean of course it doesn't mean
that a person cannot act as a tool for
my gratification if I go see the Baker
and I get bread from
him he's the method by which I get my
bread but the baker is not just a baker
he he is a full person just as myself so
when we steal or we lie or we cheat it's
because we're not considering the P the
person facing us to be a full-blown
person to be what they are according to
their logos but we see them only as
limited things only as
tools so this is true of people of
things and of
actions so I was thinking about I was
trying to think about the best example
that I could think of to to show this in
terms of action and and and uh I thought
of giving the example of of sex so we
did the metaphysics of Pepe so I think
we can get away with the metaphysics of
sex I
hope but it's a question that
desperately needs to be answered today
in our Topsy Turvy times let's say so
what is the logos of
sexuality well it has many Loi many
purposes uh it's for the propagation of
the
species I hope at least a few of you
still think that despite what many
people would want us to
believe creates families and
communities it brings two people
together in a type of
communion in an expression of love and
it brings
pleasure those so those will be would be
some of the LOI I'm sure we could find
more but some those would be some of the
L that sex exists and there could be
more but the idea in the vision of logos
is that all those things need to be
brought together in a pattern of some
sort for them to be a path towards
logos so if we think of the different
Loi and we bring them
together trying to think of the word
what is that word when we all those
things are together I think we have a
word it's the sacrament of the
church I'll let you figure it out which
what it is when all those things come
together and so each of the separate
purposes of sex that I mentioned they're
not wrong they're fine but they become
alive when we bring them
together if we don't then each separate
purpose appears as a kind of falsehood
it appears as a kind of
lacking but that's not enough let's say
for a truly traditional or a truly
complete vision of sexuality it cannot
end there it has to move towards the
infinite it has to move towards
God and so the Ultimate Logos of
sexuality is to be an image of the
mystical Union with God I mean it's to
be an image of our Union with that with
with what is beyond
us I mean in that image of the the the
mystical Union of God with with the soul
with of Christ with his church the
marriage of Heaven and Earth is a
completely traditional image that we
find in in in the church fathers or in
in our
tradition and so that that image of the
ultimate Union the highest Union with
with the
infinite then it comes back
down into the multiple Loi all those
other reasons for sexuality that I
mentioned and it fills them
and makes them participate in a
Transcendent purpose and becomes the
very relationship that binds them
together and everything in our life can
follow that process work food sleep
beauty and to engage the world in that
frame is is to find light everywhere to
see life
everywhere the world is no longer made
of the Dead lifeless dirt the dead
lifeless materal material that we use to
to make things
with and as we become better as people
more truthful more grateful more
free as we come closer to one another in
love and and by the way that's what love
is love is the manner in which all
different things all different people
all different intentions can join
together and exist in communion and can
become one while at the same
time preserving the
multiplicity so as we follow this path
the hidden Loi in creation they shine
through the
world and today we might say that they
reenchant the world and the world
appears bright and full and not the gray
and dead shadows we often live
in so that would be I hope a summary
let's say of that path of
logos but I haven't really explained
what the source of my excitement was on
that Friday night yet what the source of
the excitement was that has caused all
this flurry of attention to Jordan and I
can tell you I've been thinking about
this now for months now I mean some of
us have and Jordan has been thinking
about this for months
now and I I think by now we can say that
it's really not about gender pronouns
it's not it's about something that is a
lot bigger than
that and I think I can say confidently
by now that it's about
logos the entire project of
postmodernism the last 30 40 Years of
Higher Culture and higher education has
been a systematic assault on
logos to decenter logos to deconstruct
narratives and value hierarchies so we
are left slipping and sliding without
purpose and
Direction and now we've reached the end
of what postmodernism has to offer we
can actually say we that we've come to a
point where postmodernism has won
basically the cultural
debate and a philosophy which decries
the center and certain certainty has
pricious become the very very center and
unquestionable Authority despises so
everything is upside down everything is
inside out everything is becoming its
opposite and all these inversions and
Chaos are not to be taken lightly it has
brought about a sterile age literally
sterile as people are not having enough
children to to fill the
society I think I keep thinking that
maybe they're missing a bit of foul
centy but it's also sterile in that it
has brought about this
narcissistic and fragmented
culture you see they told us that the
center cannot
hold and now Things Fall
Apart and now everybody is decrying the
end of Truth all of a sudden right
everybody is saying that we're entering
an age of posttruth fake news I mean my
goodness they even used it in as an
argument against Dr Peterson in the
debate on gender
pronouns I mean it's the postmodernist
that heralded the end of Truth 40 years
ago and now they're surprised to see the
effect it has how chaos does not
discriminate how it's turning against
them just as they turned it against
their ideological
enemies they wanted to change the world
to sand and now they're surprised to
find it slipping between their
fingers what is most surprising and what
is most shocking to them is to find that
now having reached the end of their
Pursuit having thought they had won they
see from within the decomposing residues
of Western patriarchy they see that
there is a seed that's
sprouting that in the darkest place
there is a flame that is
lit logos
awakens the darkness has not overcome it
St John promised us
that and my postmodern friends if you
had just paid attention to the stories
if you had just paid attention to the
stories which are woven in the fabric of
our Consciousness these very stories you
tried to deconstruct you would have
noticed that Dawn always comes that it
seed is always planted their logos
regains the
center Christ rises from the
dead and I think that's the excitement
we're feeling right now to find that
small spark that seed of a meaningful
pattern surprising us in a collapsing
world and it's not just a pattern of
meaning but it's the beginning of a
network of people I mean just in the
past two years there's a whole whole new
strange group of public figures that's
arising from the margins people who are
at least trying to figure it out who are
at least trying to think clearly and
work out ideas and people who are as
different from each other as you can
imagine spanning across gender race and
cultures even religious and atheists aik
trying to figure it out and yet the
media and the activists they scream
hysterically bigot racist sexist Nazi
all the usual Litany of attacks and
they're losing their minds the sand is
slipping out of their
hand and only two years ago we would
have probably collapsed before this
attack but now we look around and we
find that there is a still silent Center
in which to s in which to stand there is
an eye in the overwhelming
hurricane and we can finally say we will
not accept your frame we will not accept
your
definitions they are weak by the very
process you use to deconstruct them to
deconstruct the categories and we will
speak for
ourselves what a
relief but it is a dangerous time the
time of transition the time of chaos is
a is a dangerous time firstly because
the enemies of logos will ramp up their
hysteria and totalitarian Tendencies as
logos
awakens but it is also dangerous because
as Christ himself told us the tears grow
amongst the
weak the reentering of logos is The
Reawakening of identities we can't avoid
that and that's a frightening thing
because if identity stops at the
relative
Loi without aiming without uniting
itself to the highest of high it can be
murderous and it has been increasingly
murderous just in the past
Century and it is in fact the very
murderous and genocidal tendency of
identity which provoked the postmoderns
to deconstruct Identity in the first
place and there's a part where we can't
blame them for
that I mean in the shadow of aitz what
else can you
do so
what will strive from this new Sprout
will depend on us will depend on all of
us what will rise from this chaos you've
seen exciting exciting but also
frightening possibilities of what that
might look like I mean will it be race
again so that we inch towards
genocide would it only be Nation so
we're tempted to revisit the world
wars will it only be gender will it only
be class and the scheme drawn out for us
by St Maximus the ultimate identity the
place where all meaning Finds Its
resolution is the Divine logos the
source of everything that is our
trajectory as we walk the path of logos
as we are transformed by truth the
finality is to be United with God
and I know that for some people just the
word god causes allergic
reactions and I'm sure people listening
to this will be developing hives on
their skin as they as they hear
this but maybe we can just think of it
this way for identity to be more than a
weapon it must reach its highest point
in something that is beyond
Duality and so finding seeing our
highest identity in God is finding
finding Unity with everything and the
source of
everything and in terms of Christianity
in
particular the identity with Christ is
different from other identities because
it's the identity with the cross I mean
it's to identify with
suffering I mean it's not the identity
of a selfs serving power but the
identity of a self emptying power of
power Bound in love that empties itself
out of
love I mean it doesn't mean that we
shouldn't struggle doesn't mean that we
should just lay down and give up that we
should let our enemies destroy what we
value most I mean c Christ bought
brought a whip into the temple after all
but what it really entails what it what
what's important about it and this is
something that is echoed profoundly in
what Dr
Peterson has been telling us is that we
must first walk on the path of logos
ourselves we must embrace our own
suffering in that truth we must take up
our
cross we must do so with the desire to
first get rid of the lies which blind us
to straighten our own path and in doing
so well that is how we will change the
world St sarim of sarov is known to have
said save yourself and thousands around
you will be
saved
as we walk on that path as we strip away
our own excesses rather than look rather
than looking at the imbalances of
others as we strip away our bad habits
and our
narcissism rather than acting like
victims the world will
change and we will start to see and to
experience logos to fully live within
the patterns of meaning that constitute
the world if you take that journey I
guarantee that the universal patterns of
meaning will manifest themselves so
strongly in your
life that at first you'll use the word
synchronicity but soon you'll have no
other word to use besides
miracle and the postmodern chaos will
vanish as wax melts before the fire and
logos the very logos that rises from the
grave will fill your world and the world
with life and light thank
[Applause]
you
so I I'm going to start with a
hypothesis and I spend a lot of time
thinking
about religious symbolism and and
archetypes but there's there's there's a
there's a problem with that and and the
problem
is it lacks concretization you know
to think about the ultimate ideal as as
as only something that's
symbolic it it moves away from the real
world and it's for it's partly for this
reason that there's an insistence in
Christianity that the logos is two
things at once it took me a long time to
to figure this out and I was guided in
my attempts to understand it by Carl
Jung who was a truly remarkable
person and probably orthodox and his
fundamental convictions I would
say he talked about the logos as the
thing that existed at the beginning of
time and this is a very particular way
of looking at things and so the idea is
essentially that as Jonathan pointed out
that there's something about
Consciousness that calls forth being
from chaotic potential and you you all
understand what this means because when
you look at the future or if you look at
yourselves you know that what you
confront is a field of potential and
everyone tells you that they tell you
you're not living up to your
potential and potential is a very
strange thing because it doesn't yet
exist and so by the Cannons of say
modern science it's not something that
has any reality whatsoever but everyone
knows precisely what it it means and
everything around you is full of
potential because you can interact with
it and bring forth new things and and
you know
that and you can be called for your
failure to do it and you you you you you
you call you call out yourself for your
failure to do it because you wake up at
3: in the morning and you and you
torture yourself with your inability to
bring forth the potential that's within
you and it and it haunts your soul and
and it's hellish and the reason it's
hellish is because it is
hellish and if you don't call forth the
potential that's within you and outside
of you then the world does transform
into hell because that's its tendency
anyways and we've had no shortage of
evidence of that in the last 100
years
it's it's part of the Christian doctrine
that at the beginning of
time the logos of
yahwa operated on potential and brought
forth habitable the habitable world
order and it was perfect in some strange
sense it was the Paradise in which Adam
and Eve were placed and the paradise was
a wall Garden a well watered place and
the wall Garden is a place of Order and
Chaos culture and nature nature and
that's because people inhabit a garden
of culture and nature that that's that's
our environment and if those two
properties are properly balanced then
inside that Garden everyone can
flourish and human beings are in
principle made in the image of that
logos and that's why we can speak things
into being and we do and when you speak
truth then you speak Paradise into being
and when you you speak falsely you speak
hell into being and that's the
truth and what that means is that with
every decision that you
make you decide for yourself and for
everyone else whether you're going to
tilt the world a little bit more towards
hell or a little bit more towards heaven
and that's the burden you bear for your
existence and the choices that you make
as you pass through life and it's the
fleeing from
that that's that at the bottom of the
nihilism of postmodernism and the Escape
into the totalitarian certainties of
idol
worship and none of this is fictional
because we've seen the
consequences Jonathan said
quoting I don't remember the source that
there could be no
poetry after
owitz but that's wrong but the Poetry
has to be about
owitz the lesson from owitz was never
again and fair enough but you
don't you
can't decide not to repeat something
terrible unless you understand
it and the way to understand it is
that the small sins of each individual
culminate in the great sins of the state
and so when you ask why terrible things
happen in the world the answer is quite
simple the answer is it's because you're
not good
enough and it's because you don't tell
the
truth and you know
it Jonathan said something I thought was
very interesting it's something I
thought about but I haven't talked to
him about it at
all what happens as you move towards the
truth and the answer is everything comes
together it really that really is the
answer is everything comes together
there's even a sexual element to that
because of course the highest element of
sexual ecstasy is to come together and
around someone who's telling the truth
everything comes together and that's the
potential Destiny of the world it's
something that you can partake in it's
the calls it's the call to The Greatest
Adventure that there is you can bring
forth something akin to Paradise by
speaking the truth and you can start in
your own life and you can start in in in
the life of your own families and these
are people in principle that you love
and so why would you do anything but
speak the truth to them to protect them
from reality there's no protecting
anyone from reality reality just
is you interact with it on your on its
terms and you do that by facing it
forthrightly and you do that by not
shying away from the
challenge I spend a lot of time trying
to understand The Sermon on the
Mount it it's a very strange
document I'm going to tell you what I
think it
means it means conceptualize the highest
good that you
can and so you might think that would be
the highest good for you and it would be
the highest good for the family around
you that you love and it would be the
highest good for that family in the
state and it would be the highest good
for the state in the world and that
would be the highest Poss good aim at
that even though you don't know how aim
at that make that what you
want and then tell the truth and it's an
adventure because you don't know what's
going to happen you have no idea because
if you treat things instrumentally if
you treat people instrumentally you use
them as tools for your own desire and
that the problem with that is what do
you know about what you desire many
things that you chase will turn out to
be
empty well what happens if you just tell
the truth
well the world will unfold around you in
very strange and mysterious ways and
there isn't anything that's more
exciting than that and it's perhaps
something exciting enough so that the
suffering that's attendant on being
would redeem Itself by that adventure
and that's the call that's the Western
call to the individual the suffering of
being can redeem itself through truth
and it's not it's it's it's not a rule
it's not a proposition that you need to
adhere to like a good citizen it's it's
it's the proper way of wending your way
through the terrible world without
making it worse than it already is with
the possibility perhaps of making it
better there's no more exciting
possibility than that and no higher
moral demand and the thing is is
everyone knows it you know when you lie
according to your own conception of the
truth that there's something something
shameful and demeaning about that and
you know that it hurts people and you
think well why do you do it despite all
that and partly you do it because it's
easy and partly do you do it because
there's a crooked horrible hellish part
of your soul that's more than happy if
part of what you do is make everything
worse to pay for the sin of its
existence and I would say we should stop
doing that and see what we could do if
we got ourselves together because human
beings are remarkable
creatures we put together a an amazing
civilization working at it half time you
know it's like 55% of
Humanity on a good day is working to
make things better and 45% is working to
make it worse and you wonder what would
happen if we all just decided that we
were going to make things better as
simple as that start where you are make
things around you
better where would we be what would the
world turn into around a civilization of
people who were genuinely trying to make
things better I can tell you we better
find out soon because if we don't try
collectively to make things better given
the current state of affairs they are
going to get a lot
worse I thought for a long time I
wondered why people find themselves a
drift in meaninglessness and there's a
lot of answers to that there's the
classical criticisms of traditional
faith that have been put forth by
brilliant people like Fredick nche
there's the idea that there were fairy
tales that people lived by prior to the
Modern Age and we've outgrown those and
that's left this in a cosmos that's
pered meaning and so it's a consequence
of the inevitable unfolding of a kind of
cutting rationality and some of that's
true but there's a lot of it that isn't
true you know because I've also come to
understand that the reason that so many
of us Proclaim that life is meaningless
is because we actually would rather have
it be meaningful less than to take
responsibility for it because you can
imagine this you can imagine this
scenario imagine you were offered a
choice and and this is because you are
offered this choice you could say well
absolutely nothing you do matters and
Who the hell's going to know anyways in
a million years and so you can do
whatever you want moment to moment right
that's the payoff for that perspective
is you can do whatever you want moment
to moment and you'll not be held
responsible by anyone including yourself
for pursuing your petty impulsive
immoral foolish destructive
genocidal Tendencies or the alternative
is that you can assume that everything
you do is Meaningful and everything you
do has an impact on the way the world
unfolds and take responsibility for that
and it'll it's something that it'll have
your meaning all right that's for sure
because you have an infinite amount of
responsibility for every mistake that
you make under those circumstances and
perhaps as a as a a a medicament for
that the knowledge that when you're on
the path properly that you're helping
the world
unfold in the best direction that it
possibly could well there isn't anything
better than that if you want something
to set against the inevitable suffering
of of
life that's what you said against it the
endless adventure of trying to make
things better in every possible way and
God only knows where we could get if we
did that around the perfect man
everything comes together and I don't
believe that that's that's that's where
the infinite logos that exet that
stretches across time and space comes
together in a single individual that's
the Christian story and the reason for
that is is that every single person is
embedded in a specific time and place
that's you as an individual but at the
same point you're also the embodiment of
this thing that has across forever to
call chaos into habitable being you're
both this Divine Eternal Transcendent
Essence and the finite shell that you
inhabit it's like the
genie right a genie is genius and the
genie is something that can grant three
Magical Wishes but has to inhabit this
tiny little space it's the same idea
well you can act that out in your life
and you can transcend it and as you do
that things come together around you and
everything becomes musical that's the
right way to think about it and
everything becomes alive and you shy
away from that because you're resentful
about the fundamental structure of being
and you don't want the
responsibility and it's no bloody Wonder
because the responsibility is the
responsibility for everything you know
that's why it's part of the Christian
story that Christ took the sins of the
world upon himself because that's what
you have to do in order to put yourself
together it's your
fault everything that isn't going right
is because you're not good enough well
who wants
that right welcome the postmodernists
because they'll lighten the burden the
consequences that nothing has any
meaning but that's a small price to pay
to get rid of that particular burden
well maybe not maybe the meaning of life
is to be found in your voluntary
willingness to take on that burden and
carry it right well that's the notion
that's embedded in the idea of the Cross
right to pick up a full conscious
knowledge of your own vulnerability your
your subjugation to betrayal your T your
your slavery at the hands of the state
your insanity and your mortality and to
say I'll bear that
voluntarily it's okay I can handle
it it seems to me that we're at a kind
of
Crossroads I don't know exactly why you
always meet the devil at the crossroads
by the way and the reason for that is
because every Crossroads is a choice
right and it's always a choice between
Good and Evil
we're at a Crossroads and I don't know
why I guess it's because the terrible
20th century has spent its energy and
now we have something new in the
aftermath of that it's time for everyone
to pick up the chaotic pieces and to
carry them voluntarily and to make their
way through the world and to try to
speak their truth and to see what
happens it will heal yourself it will
heal your body it will heal your soul it
will heal your family it'll heal the
nation that's what truth does and how
could it be any other way reality is the
truth and how are you going to adapt to
it without using the truth well the
problem is reality is the terrible truth
but it's certainly possible that the
terrible truth is its own
medicine with regards to my connection
to Orthodoxy I have kind of a funny
story to tell about
that about 15 years
ago a student of mine
who who I've maintained a relationship
with since I taught it at
Harvard
um I'd helped him through a difficult
period he his family had been at the
center of a real storm of publicity like
this a front page story for a number of
months recently he returned the favor
with me
but he proposed at one point that I fly
down to Los Angeles and act as the
officient at his marriage and I thought
that's pretty interesting I never
expected that to happen and so I thought
well if I'm going to do that I better
get ordained because that's obviously
the logical thing to do and I thought
well how do you get ordained on short
notice and obviously the answer to that
is you you go online and
so so I went online and I I signed up I
could name my church so I did I I have
this church I'm the only
member
it's called the it's called The Church
of the Spirit of St Yim of Flores which
you know isn't necessarily the name that
you would expect um I liked St Yim from
what I knew of him because he had this
idea that there were
three epochs there would be three epochs
in western civilization and one would be
the epoch of the father that's roughly
the Old Testament Epoch Old Testament
morality that has to do with following
rules and then there was the epoch of
the Sun and that was of course Epoch the
Christian Epoch of the last 2,000 years
and he believed that what would come
after that would be the epoch of the
Holy Ghost and the Holy Ghost is this
weird Spirit thing that hypothetically
Christ left behind that could inhabit
people and guide them on their path and
and it seems to me that that's very much
in keeping with the Orthodox idea that
the proper um moral pathway for each
individual to take is to attempt to Bear
the burden of the perfect individual
right to become Christ so to speak and
attempt to transcend mortality
infinitude and to and to unite with God
and I thought well that was kind of a
cool idea so I thought well I might as
well have that as a church and then I
thought who should I be in this church
and I thought well Pope was probably a
little bit on the uh narcissistic side
let's say so I thought I'll be
Metropolitan because I thought that was
kind of archaic enough and and sort of
out of the way enough so that it was a
good joke so I'm my own metropolit my
own church it only has one rule and so
you can join it if you want um the rule
is that if you're a member of my church
you can't follow stupid
rules yeah so that's a good rule because
it's actually it's an anti- rule rule la
which is really funny as far as I'm
concerned anyways I went down to LA and
I did marry these two and they're still
married and so that's good uh and yeah
yeah so I know that's a bit rambly but
it's been a long day
um I talked to Sam Harris today again
for those of you who it went
great yeah went great anyway so look the
idea is pretty straightforward you know
as far as I can tell there's this
tremendous idea that's at the bottom of
Western culture that's taken the human
race Millennia and perhaps an endless
amount of time before then an eternal
amount of time before then to formulate
and the idea is that our Consciousness
and that's the center of us the soul
whatever that happens to
be partakes in the process by which
creation comes into being and we do that
through the logos which is our capacity
to think and to utter words and to
engage in dialogue but more importantly
to do that truthfully and that to the
degree that we're able to do that
truthfully we bring Paradise into being
rather than hell and it seems to me that
that's as close to objective reality
although it's not precisely objective
it's more than objective reality it's a
kind of meta reality it's it's the most
profound truth that you'll ever
encounter and the thing that's cool
about it is you can even you can put it
to the test if you want you know you
start deciding that you're not going to
lie because how the hell are you going
to tell the truth what do you know you
don't know what the truth is but you
certainly know when you're lying and you
know how to stop doing that so I would
say well just try stop lying and see
what happens try it for like a year you
don't get to lie about anything anymore
and that also means you can't do things
that you would be afraid to talk about
because you know if you're going to tell
the truth you have to tell the truth
about what you did and if you do
reprehensible things then you can't just
run around telling everybody about them
so it also means that you have to not
act in a way that you wouldn't speak
truthfully about and just try it you'll
find out first of all that you're so
full of lies and deceit that you just
bloody well can't believe it when I
started doing this 30 years ago it
really just about drove me crazy because
I divided into two people in some sense
and one person one one person was
talking and the other person was
watching the person that was talking and
the talking person was a puppet and the
watching person was the right person and
every time the talking person said
something the watching person would go
you don't believe that that isn't true
that isn't your idea and I thought wow
that's really not good because it looks
like 95% of what I'm saying isn't mine
or I'm saying it for show or I'm saying
it to be dominant primate or I'm saying
it so that I can be you know so that I
can use my language instrumentally and
get what I want or or you know I swiped
it from the book and I really don't
deserve it but I'm saying it and like it
was horrible it was 95% seriously and so
then I learned at least in part to only
say things that made me feel like I was
together and that's part of that coming
together you can feel that physically
you know if you if you say something
deceitful you shrink and you cower from
it it makes you embarrassed and it makes
you weak you can feel the weakness it's
like well stop saying things that make
you weak if you don't want to be weak
then if you want to be strong stop
saying things that make you feel weak
try it try it see what happens you can
test this out in a year things will be
way different for you and five years you
won't even be the same person and God
only knows what will happen in the decad
so it's really worth it besides you
don't have anything better to do anyways
because here you are you know suffering
stupidly away you might as well do
something useful with your time while
you're waiting to die
so and there isn't anything more
interesting to do than that it's so cool
because and I mean it's part of what I
decided to do last September when I made
these you know crazy videos which really
have more of an effect than I certainly
thought they would I thought well I've
got some things to say and why don't I
say them and see what happens it's like
that's sort of that's an excellent way
to live why don't I say the things that
I think and see what
happens well this is one of the things
that's happened so that's kind of cool I
mean how unlikely is this it's
completely absurd and ridiculous that
that here I'm with Jonathan this crazy
French Canadian har and these two guys
in dresses here I
mean it's exactly that's exactly what
you'd expect given what I've been
talking about
recently this is very unlikely and all
this has been very unlikely and life is
very unlikely and you know maybe it
could be absolutely magnificent and
wonderful we could make everything into
a holy Temple in which we could live
forever peacefully only searching for
more remarkable and spectacular things
to do next and that's what people people
do in Paradise they sit around dreaming
about how the paradise they already had
could give rise to a paradise that's yet
greater than the one that's there and
with the collective imagination that we
pursue that could be a never ending
thing and we could bring it into being
and that's what we should do because the
alternative is to let everything
degenerate into chaos and hell and how
about we don't do
that well that's good
[Applause]
enough
um thank you to Metropolitan Jordan of
Toronto um I just wanted to quickly say
that uh following father Jeff's talk we
will have a question and answer period
so so uh 5 minutes from now uh we'll
have people walking by the aisles taking
your um question sheets as well as on
the balcony so um and uh after father
Jeffrey talk will'll have the question
answer period And if you have more
questions after that we'll collect those
as well just pass them up and if you're
on the balcony just give them to Aiden
thank you very much and father
Jeffrey
good
evening Father Ted and I have had a kind
a running debate over the last few weeks
as to what would be worse going first or
going
last how do I follow
that we'll
see the second century Church did
something rather strange and quite
astonishing stories about Jesus which
had been circulating orally for some
generations began to be written down in
the second half of the first century
there were numerous versions in
circulation which came over time to be
associated with the traditions of one or
another Apostolic witness to the Risen
Lord
Jesus and a certain point a choice had
to be made the church could have come up
with a definitive account the single
canonical
version that approach was was certainly
a Temptation one of the first to do this
was a dualistic heretic called Marci he
settled on one gospel the Gospel of Luke
as it happens he liked that one which he
reacted however to suit his
vision incidentally he also rejected the
entire Old Testament in the process
teaching that matter was evil and
therefore the Creator God of the Old
Testament was responsible for it all but
the point here is that he wanted a
single gospel to reflect Jesus who he
saw as offering salvation from this
material
world that was a heretic this single
this idea of a single gospel continued
to be a Temptation even for those within
the canonical Church in the middle of
the 2 century and otherwise quite
Orthodox believer tasan apparently
scandalized by the plurality of the
gospels created his famous
diesso in this he wo the gospel accounts
into one seamless consistent narrative
and it had some traction in fact for
some centuries particularly among the
syak uh tradition this was the main
gospel Ed but the church rejected both
of these
attempts and from the beginning of the
process of the canonization of the New
Testament it accepted that there should
be different gospels leading the charge
was the second century Bishop of Leon
irus who insisted on what he called the
Evangelion tetramorph the fourfold
gospel
already in his days day those were the
four gospels we have in our new
testament
today this is important fully aware of
the significant differences in the
accounts not only different emphases and
Theological Visions but
contradictions the church chose to
canonize
diversity it chose to retain four
separate and distinctive literary
compositions witnessing to the life
death and resurrection of Jesus
this is interesting for all kinds of
reasons and of course it points to the
experience of Jesus being more profound
than any one account could capture but
not least and for our purposes and theme
tonight it also says something about the
meaning of what it is to be
human as New Testament scholar Luke
Timothy Johnson writes the diversity of
the Gospel accounts signifies the
infinite repli replicability of the
story of Jesus in the lives of human
beings the story of Jesus is not simply
the past the church declares but
continues as the spirit of Jesus
transforms the lives of human beings
according to the mind of
Christ but in what sense can the story
of Jesus be
replicated surely not in the specifics
of his ministry which are irretrievably
in the past it's not about being a CIB
bearded Jewish male growing up in
Galilee in the first century Palestine a
techno someone who works with his hands
like his foster father such historical
elements are not repeatable neither are
they important to
repeat rather the plurality of the
gospels in their variety of and
contradictory historical details points
beyond all this to a deeper
significance that is to the meaning of
the story of Jesus contained these
narratives it's not the facts of Jesus's
life that matter and find new expression
in the lives of others but rather the
pattern of his
existence Jesus existence as one of
radical obedience towards God and
selfless service towards others forms a
pattern for all Humanity that can be
written in the Heart by the holy
spirit it's this pattern that Paul
designates as the normal
often translated the law of Christ but
it's better understood perhaps as the
pattern of Christ the pattern of the
Messiah as an aside this concept of the
pattern of Christ etched into the
multiform narratives that witness to the
life death and resurrection of Jesus was
also the reason for the limits that were
placed on what could be considered
gospel you see if diversity was not just
allowed but a requirement to express the
fullness of Truth the was nevertheless a
bridge too far and the rejection of the
so-called Gnostic Gospels with which I'm
sure many of you are familiar was
precisely that they were not
narratives but often just collections of
sayings and that makes sense the
gnostics were not interested in the
material world and to have a story
requires
materiality their sacred texts much as
much as they purported to be about Jesus
lacked precisely The Narrative element
of the pattern of Christ now time does
not suffice for us to explore together
this evening how across all the various
writings of the New
Testament this underlying pattern of
Christ emerges permit me to outline the
very briefest of sketches in the four
gospels in the letters of Paul and the
other early Apostles behind all the
collected
facts there's a deep consistency in the
earliest Christian literature concerning
a focus not on wondrous Deeds or even
wise words but on the character of Jesus
as Messiah on the meaning of his life
and death they all
reveal the same pattern of radical
obedience to God and Selfless Love
towards other people they reveal a
journey that plunges to the depths of
alienation in solidarity with all and
then rises in glorification having not
merely overcome suffering sin and death
but emptied them of their power they
reveal a pattern of Joyful sacrifice
voluntary death and glorious
resurrection and they also all agree on
this that discipleship is to follow the
same Messianic pattern they don't
emphasize that followers of Jesus
perform certain Deeds or learn certain
doctrines they insist rather on living
according to the same pattern of life
and death shown by Jesus
to be a Christian therefore is not about
Dogma or even morality although there
are dogmatic and ethical implications
it's not about all that religious
baggage we so often associate with it it
is to live it is for each of us to enact
in our unique human existence the nomos
the pattern of
Christ now there are numerous ways we
can describe this pattern of Christ for
instance the Eastern father's principal
mode of exegesis of understanding
scripture is
typology so we can add to pattern the
word pattern another word toos or type A
type is a person an object or an event
that is connected across SpaceTime to
others without losing its own historical
reality and identity it shares in a
greater reality of meaning that greater
reality which it points a greater
reality called the antiy
this is how the apostles and the church
fathers read the entire Old Testament
for example Adam St Paul says is a Tios
a type of Christ the first created man
pointing forward to the recreation of
the human right race in Christ Jesus The
Exodus narrative as an event is a type
of the true Passover or Pasa Christ
Deliverance of all people from suffering
and death and anyone who's familiar with
the writings of the church fathers or of
the Liturgy of your Orthodox Church will
know how abundant types are within
them but this is the key typology is not
just a way of reading and understanding
history and texts seeing how people and
events Point towards Christ typology is
for Eastern fathers the fundamental
structure of reality of a world that is
symbolic of an an epiphany or theophany
of God and of our own apprehension of
this reality our own finding of meaning
within it so it's not just figures from
scriptural history that are types we too
are called to typify Christ to be
symbols of Christ participants in his
archetypal journey and life his descent
in self offering and his Ascent in
glory if we are to be truly human we
must follow what distinguished scholar
of this University northr fry calls the
new shaped story that is the foundation
not only of biblical narrative and the
Christ story but of story after Story
myth after myth in Christ the archetype
of archetypes we have in the words of CS
Lewis myth become
fact as we've already heard this evening
in the gospel of St John of course this
pattern is above all called Lobos it's
not an abstract pattern but it's a
direct and in these latter days in the
fullness of time a direct incarnate
expression of God himself the logos is
the principle of order and creation as
we've heard it's through the logos that
God speaks and all things are made it is
logos God's verb perhaps better than
word verb in whose image we are created
whose likeness we are called to attain
and the L lesson here is simply this
that a properly ordered human life is
one lived in accordance with the
logos the concept of logos has a long
and venerable history and it did even
before the Greek translators of the Old
Testament and the New Testament writers
appropriated it and one of the first or
the first of the Greek philosophers to
speak of logos was the presocratic
heraclitus and he said this to
lendos
although logos is common to all all have
the logos the many live as if they had a
wisdom of their
own in other words logos May govern the
universe the macro Cosmos and our own
inner world the mro cosmos but most
people don't choose a properly ordered
life a life aligned with the compass
built into the fabric of the world built
into their own hearts and
Minds we've heard already we are now in
the season of great lent the great 40
days as it's called and this has many
significances it's a season of course of
aesthetic labor of renewal of faith
redoubling of our commitment to prayer
and the service of others it's also the
season of preparing cumans for
baptism above all though it's the season
where we're called to come to our senses
and to awake to the fundamental meaning
shape and pattern of our Our Lives we
realize our alienation we repent M we
embark on our journey of return a
journey which involves self- sacrifice a
journey which
necessarily passes through our own
voluntary death and Resurrection lent is
in essence the totality of our life but
it requires the remembrance of
death there was a famous practice in
ancient r Rome as a general came back
Victorious from a battle and during his
triumphant parade would would receive
compliments and honors from the crowd of
citizens he ran the risk of falling
victim to his own pride and delusions of
grandeur and to avoid that a slave would
be placed just behind him Whispering
into his ear
saying look after you to the time of
your death and remember you're only a
man thereafter it was enrin and picked
up in Christian tradition as momento
Mori remember that you will
die but better yet remember to
die remember to die might think we need
that remembrance but because eventually
all of us will probably prove equal to
the
task but remember to die because
remember to find and follow the logos
the pattern of our true life which
passes through death to Resurrection
it's a very frequent theme in patristic
Tradition St Gregory the Theologian
often repeats the saying of Plato which
suggests that the present life ought to
be a meditation upon death and he
invited his friend fagos to live instead
of the present the future and make this
life a meditation and practice of death
you could go on from the church fathers
the focus on death is is front and
center remembrance of our journey that
passes from from Death to life this is
also the connection of lent with the
preparation for baptism baptism in its
deepest and primary sense signifies
death and burial and Resurrection with
Christ this is very clear in Romans
chapter 6 The epistle which we read on
the eve of Easter pasca we have been
baptized into Christ's death we have
been buried with him by baptism into
death we have been United to Christ in a
death like his and United to him in his
Resurrection like his so baptism means
death and Resurrection St Gregory of
Nissa says the font is both tomb and
mother the Orthodox Theologian Paul
evdokimov writes about this thing it's
an extended quotation if you'll bear
with me baptism he says means sharing
mystically in Christ's death and his
burial but also in what happened between
his burial
and his resurrection in his descent into
hell what is the meaning of the
Incarnation God becoming truly human in
Christ identifies himself with all human
anguish alienation and despair In The
Garden of Gethsemane he says my soul is
exceedingly sorrow even unto death he
shares in the fullness of human pain he
enters into the fullness not only of
human life but of human death and we are
to understand Christ's descent into hell
as being the full expression of God's
solidarity with our human
alienation Christ descends into the hell
of human suffering and of human lonely
loneliness and human despair surely he
has borne our griefs and carried our
sorrows as we read in the book of Isaiah
and we may add that Christ has borne all
our griefs all our sorrows there is a
total identification here an unreserved
erve solidarity of Christ Our God in our
human fallenness he who is sinless yet
became sin for us became one with us in
our fallen State as St Paul says and
that is part of the meaning of this
descent into Hell All Things Are full of
God even hell though I go down to Hell
Thou Art there also we read in Psalm
138 so when we are baptized if doimo
continues we descend with Christ into
hell we also also commit ourselves in
solidarity with Christ to the same total
unreserved identification with those who
suffer each of the baptized becomes by
virtue of his descent into hell with
Christ a man or a woman for others each
of us is called to Bear the griefs of
others and to carry their
sorrows to be a Christian nay to be a
human requires us to journey to hell it
is in yung's terms to journey to hell
and become hell
oneself that's how we can make sense of
the words of a great Elder of the 20th
century St sopon who when a a young monk
asked him how will we be saved answered
keep your mind in hell and despair
not why hell why this archetypal descent
before ascending why the you pattern of
Christ that we must
follow um as a an amateur of physics if
you will indulge me let me offer a
metaphor from physics and I'm borrowing
this from a scholar of Orthodox
Christian liturgy David F
Ferber Archimedes was a Greek physicist
who was fascinated by the mechanic
mathematics of the lever and you may
remember from your science classes and
simple machines that a lever is used to
exert a large force over a small
Distance by exerting a small force over
a greater distance at the other end
a child can thus lift with one hand a
man standing on the short end of the be
if the child presses down on the long
end of the Archimedes was so fascinated
by the lever's potential that one day he
famously exclaimed give me a lever and a
place to stand and I shall move the
earth now he realized he needed three
things in order to move the earth a long
enough lever a correctly placed fulcrum
point and a place to stand
but that of course was the problem when
it comes to moving the Earth how could
he apply leverage to the world when he
himself was standing on the world how
could he step off the thing he lives on
in order to move it he has no
footing so in philosophy the riddle
becomes known as searching for the
archimedian point that is an objective
standpoint removed from the object of
study this hypothetical point of
perspective is thought to be far enough
removed from something in order to
afford an outsider's view of
but how can we remove ourselves to a
point outside ourselves this is our
Human Condition Augustine defines sin as
incurvatus insan being curved in upon
oneself a life oriented inwardly towards
self rather than outwardly towards God
and others our egocentrism exerts so
strong a gravitational pull that it
bends the light of Glory back on
ourselves
that light that should be glorifying God
how can we move ourselves off center
when we are the center of our universe
we have no leverage over sin we have no
standpoint outside our vanity and pride
we have no rock on which to stand that
is beyond our self-interest whoever
desires to get outside himself needs
some sort of archimedian Point Beyond
himself our self offering and our sent
to hell is precisely this archimedian
point if we are to lift the world if we
are to transform the world into a true
symbol and epiphany of God's own life
then we must first descend we cannot
lift up the world in sacrificial pra so
long as we place our footing on the
world alone it is like trying to lift
the carpeting while we stand on it
ares's problem was applying leverage to
a world that he could not step off of in
order to move it but we can by dying
with Christ we are freed from the world
we leave the world for the sake of the
world we die so that we and the world
with us may live this is not merely our
spiritual life our religious vocation
some crazy notion dreamed up by men in
black
dresses it is our true life it is our
proper life it is our life ordered
according to the Lobos and it is a
journey we must undertake we undertake
not on our own but only in Christ for
Christ and Christ Alone is the one who
took that Journey so that we could be
reconciled to
God in closing I would like to turn to
one of the greatest in my own estimation
Poets of the past Century one who saw
deeply into these realities of logos of
Journey Through death and
Resurrection in his poem the waste land
TS Elliot depicts a bleak and sterile
world it's a world in which we fail to
take up our journey where we stay put
amidst a civilization that's been
reduced to a wasteland that has lost its
fertility and its ability to bring forth
life the world is filled he says with a
heap of broken
images and the dead tree gives no
shelter there is no easy fix and
certainly nothing in That civilization
or Society could
offer there is no leverage does such a
world sound familiar to us
today we need to look at Elliot's final
work the four quartets for Hope of
renewal and spiritual replenishment
tellingly above this series of four
poems the last that he wrote he's
inscribed those words of heraclitus that
I mentioned before although logos is
common the many live as if they had
wisdom of Their Own Elliot gets it the
solution to our Wasteland is not renewed
civilization per se on its own terms but
a journey undertaken in the pattern of
the
logos he says this it's a symbol
perfected in
death all shall be well and all manner
of things shall be well by the
purification of the motive in the ground
of our
beseeching he goes on to evoke an image
this beautiful image of the fire of the
Holy Spirit purifying as a d purifying
the world as it descends as a d and he
ends with this on a hopeful l in which
descent to death is the source of life
and meaning and
transformation we die with the
dying see they depart and we go with
them we are born with the dead see they
return and bring us with them the moment
of the Rose and the moment of the UT
tree are of equal duration a people
without history is not redeemed from
time for history is a pattern of
Timeless moments so while the light
fails on a Winter's afternoon in a
secluded Chapel history is now and
England with the drawing of this love
and the voice of this calling we shall
not cease from exploration and the end
of all our exploring will be to arrive
where we
started and in the beginning of
the and know the place for the first
time through the unknown remembered gate
when the last of the earth left to
discover is that which was the beginning
at the source of the longest river the
voice of the Hidden waterfall and the
children in the apple tree not known
because not looked for but her halfway
in the Stillness between two waves of
the sea quick now here now now always a
condition of complete Simplicity costing
not less than
everything and all shall be well and all
manner of things shall be well when the
tongues of flame are infolded into the
crowned knot of fire and the fire and R
[Applause]
are
[Music]
what an amazing ending to our
discussions can I just get another round
of applause for all our
[Applause]
[Music]
panelists so it's 8:47 right now but
just letting you guys know even though
uh the event says that the event ends at
900 p.m. we do have the room till 10: so
we have plenty of time for questions um
so with that said if you guys have any
more questions that develop along the
way you can just write them down and
pass them up and I will try to get to as
many as possible and I'll also try to
ask questions that kind
of answer as many other questions as
possible so with that
said and this question does not address
to any panelist in particular by
whichever you feels like you would like
to answer this question um please do so
a statue in Rome depicts the suffering
of the Trojan priest lokan if I'm
pronouncing that correctly and his
sons unlike the noble suffering of
Christ lokan suffer lokan suffering
seems neither rewarded nor Justified do
these two differing visions of suffering
form part of the Divide between
postmodernists and their opponents and
do the postmodernists justify their
nihilism and or believe in other
ideologies by pointing to the pointless
suffering of lean and others like
him you don't have harder
question well you'll be answering this
one
first would you like to anyone
it's about
sculpture meaning well in that case just
meaningless
suffering is that the core of the
postmodern understanding of the problems
in the
world I don't know if it's at the core
precisely of the postmodernists view I
think it's at the core
of the problem that every human being
has with manifesting sufficient Faith to
engage fully in life mean we look at our
lives and and the lives of others and we
see that the one certainty is suffering
and and loss and we're at least in
principle the only creatures that are
aware of that that's really the story in
in Genesis of Adam and Eve right because
Adam and Eve wake up and become aware of
their own nakedness their finitude their
mortality and that throws them out of
the paradise of being and that's that's
precisely right that's the situation we
all find ourselves in the fundamental
question is all that without ultimate
meaning and it's a very profound
question the answer seems to be
something like it's without meaning
unless you take it on voluntarily and
and I don't I certainly don't understand
the full implications of that answer
although I know that in so far as you
can test that as a theory in your own
life it seems extraordinarily
robust to the degree that it's a
postmodern issue I think that the
postmodernists postmodernists feed us
very thin GRL because they offer nothing
in the face of that suffering
except the collapse of everything into
the sand that Jonathan spoke of
so that's the best I can do with
that to Mr Pou how do your icons and
icons in general function on their
day-to-day search for the
logos
um I think I think they there's many
ways in which they
function uh one of the things that I
that I talked about is the idea that the
the path of logos is a path of coming
together um and and one of the things
that icons provide is that image of
coming together so when you engage with
an icon especially in a church where
there are many icons and and many Saints
then you get that sense of uh your path
being one in which you are in communion
with others and so for orthodox
Christians for example when we pray
before icons we we we pray before them
because through the through those images
we
um we can we can how can I say this in a
in a way that can everybody can
understand so so the image becomes a
vehicle for the presence of that person
into our prayer lives and there's this
relationship which is which is set up
and so that's that is how we live with
icons and icons become a a vehicle for
that uh for that path towards towards
Unity so I hope that help that's on
let's say on a
experiential uh sense I think in on a
technical sense in terms of the the
making of icons for
myself uh for me that's what they have
done exactly is that my struggle in life
before I became Orthodox was how to fit
art that I loved into my life how to
make that fit and how for it to all come
together and in discovering the language
of traditional Christian art I found how
here's this art which is both grounded
in absolute
practical use in the lives of people
it's it's used in people's devotions
it's used in the church to teach and to
participate in the Liturgy uh and at the
same same time I can participate in that
by making them uniting me with with the
tradition of all the fathers before me
uniting me with the church and at the
same time these images what they're
talking about and what they're revealing
is that Ultimate Reality that reality
that is beyond all realities and so
being able for myself I feel a
great um blessing to have the chance and
have the the blessing of the church to
be able to to do that for a living it's
amazing every day I get to participate
in that process and so uh that's my
other answer to that
question just quickly um to add to that
point icons in the Orthodox Church are
not merely seen but they teach us to see
um you will have noted that there is a
they're not just an aesthetically
beautiful medium they have a kind of
stylization to them even even though the
many styles of iconography they share a
characteristic and there is something
about them that forces the viewer to
reflect and to come to a new way of
seeing so icons are not merely
symbols as such but they teach us to
understand all of reality in that
symbolic sense that I spoke of earlier
that that everything ultimately isn't
referencing itself that's the problem
that we're in that things have become
self-referential that everything in the
world is an icon is a symbol of God and
is referring to something much more than
what it is beyond itself without losing
its identity so icons teach us that
Vision not just depict it that makes
sense teach us a way of
seeing just to quickly add to that um
following up what Professor Peterson
said um there's the average person wants
to um to take the easy route right so
when you take a look at icons in
Orthodox Churches a lot of people have
never seen them before they say well
those are weird they they're not
realistic they're very strange looking
uh they're done on purpose because the
icon involves you okay it forces
engagement with the lcos what we've been
speaking about tonight because from the
colors that are used to you know the
subtle code that exists within
iconography that okay if you haven't
studied it you wouldn't know but if for
the people who read up on it and begin
to engage um it forces you to read the
icon and to get deeper and deeper into
what it's trying to tell you even the
perspective and Jonathan knows this very
well in most icons not all but in most
uh Byzantine icons the perspective is
even reversed you know for those of you
taking basic art you know vanishing
point is far away right things get
further away when you get when you get
when you look when you look into the
distance and things get bigger when they
get closer to you but if you look at the
geometry of an icon a lot of times
you'll see that it's reversed why
because the vanishing point is actually
pointing towards
you towards the viewer which means that
when you look at it you become part of
it and the orientation of the icon is
actually looking at you you're not just
looking at the icon the icon is looking
at you and that force a type of
involvement and it's hard work because
you have to learn how to read it you
can't just look at it and I don't want
to contrast it as with with for example
Renaissance painting as better or worse
it's just two different things but when
you look at Renaissance painting it's
realism it's just it's there to depict
what exists as it is and there's not a
lot of work there there's a lot of work
from a from a technical point of view
but to look at it you know there's it is
what it is it stops there whereas the
icon as as Jonathan was saying kind of
reveals another world the world that
could be the world that we would want to
be um um and and and that is a beautiful
thing because it's a constant engagement
with with um with our hope in the
Eternal thank you um this question is
for Jordan Peterson can you comment on
the cyclical or non-cyclical pattern of
history and if our society is doomed to
Decay or can it be renewed culturally
or in order of society State and
laws well I would say it's cyclical at
every moment in some
sense it's it's nested patterns of
cyclicality I I think you can hear that
best and the best representation I've
ever seen of that is in box brandenberg
keros they're they're they're really
worth a listen um the new videos I'm
going to release that I'm doing with
interviews use box third Brandon BG
andero which is an absolutely phenomenal
piece of music because it it cycles and
climbs continually and stays in the same
place I have no idea how he managed it
it's it's absolutely
overwhelming and that's what history is
like the apocalypse is always on us
right I mean you all confront an
apocalyptic destiny because you're all
going to die and everything comes to an
end and everything is continually
regenerated and so that cyclicality is
built into every moment that's the
u-shaped Journey that northr fry talked
about too which is order the descent
into chaos and the reestablishment of
order and everyone knows what that means
in their own life you're somewhere
stable where you understand everything
and things are going well for you and
then the rug is pulled out from
underneath your feet and you don't know
where you are you fall into chaos
someone Close to You dies or you don't
get the promotion you were looking for
some dream collapses on you or you
discover a new fault that you were never
aware of before and you fall into this
chaotic State and in that chaotic State
that's the underworld of Mythology and
one of the suburbs of the of the
Underworld the most horrific suburb of
the underworld is hell because when you
go into the underworld in chaos it's
easy to become desperate and then angry
and then vengeful and then murderous and
that that happens to people with a
tremendous tremendous frequency if you
haven't observed that in your own life
you haven't watched your own inter
interior uh landscape with with any
degree of accuracy and so that
cyclicality is is built into everything
and it's the structure of it's the
structure of being that's the right way
to think about it and now I I think the
optimistic part of that is that there is
a spiral upward as far as I can tell or
at least they can be and you get some
sense of that when when you participate
in your own life in the sense that
you've found a good direction and that's
that's imbuing you with a sense of
positive meaning and I really regard I
don't regard positive meaning as an
epiphenomenal manifestation of a deeper
material reality I don't believe that's
true at all I believe that there is
nothing more real than that sense of of
engaged meaning I think your nervous
system is actually evolved to tell you
when you're in the right place at the
right time it's something that informs
you that's literally beyond your senses
but but it's absolutely Central to
proper being you can tell when you're
engaged with the world properly because
all of a sudden the world becomes
worthwhile around you and that's that's
that's not an illusion we've been taught
for so long that meaning is some sort of
Illusion or an epiphenomena I think it's
absolutely Central and certainly no one
ever thinks that suffering is an
epiphenomena everyone acts as if their
own suffering is the most real thing
there is is and so and and no wonder so
if you experience something that enables
you to transcend that suffering or to
justify it in your own life which is
that sense of meaningful engagement why
wouldn't you regard that as even more
real than pain the only thing more real
than pain is that which can transcend it
and you can experience that in your own
life you do that all the time when
you're in the right place at the right
time it's a real thing and I also think
that's the place that truth puts you
well now how that relates to the sick
fality well that's the pathway out of it
you know that life is order chaos
reestablishment of order and you could
say well you're the order or you could
say you're the chaos and lots of people
are the chaos or maybe you're even a
denisen of hell inside that chaos or
you're the reestablished order and all
of those things are reasonable things to
be but the most reasonable thing to be
is the thing that constantly moves along
that pathway ever upwards like like that
staircase at the back which is what that
represents it's that spiral upwards you
know that leads us up into the Beyond
That's The Stairway to Heaven that
cyclicality and and it's it's it's a
genuine thing and you you know it but
you don't know you know it and some of
these stories the icons that Jonathan
produces in these stories that we've
been talking about are Humanity's
attempts to make that pattern articulate
and all we've really managed so far is
to capture it in image and story we
haven't been able to make it fully
articulate but the time for that I would
say is approaching because we need to
understand these things consciously so
that we can participate in them
properly thank
you uh this one I suppose would be most
appropriate for our Reverend fathers
what role does Jesus Christ and the
church play in helping us become more
like God is it possible to become like
God without this person and this
institution
one wants to
start this is obviously one of the hotly
debated um subjects in church history
it's also a major subject in the New
Testament we've been teaching New
Testament this term and reading Paul
recently and Paul wrestles with with
this question you know how is it you
know under the law outside of how do
people you know come
to uh this sort of center of being this
this fulfillment of of Humanity's
potential human flourishing you know
with or or without Christ and I you know
depending on how the question is asked
you will get different different answers
but I would just recall one of the main
themes from tonight which is that
logos is
inherent this isn't something that's
been kind of concocted and and posited
as some sort of philosophical you know
premise wouldn't it be nice if we all
kind of agreed with this idea and then
kind of move towards it together even
even if it was that it would be a good
thing but it's so much more fundamental
than that every human being not just
those who adhere to this
philosophy has the image of God within
them and is and is operating to some
degree or another according to the logos
in fact the Eastern tradition would tend
to argue that our very existence is good
and therefore every human being is good
in so far as they exist if if if there
was no goodness in us we would not exist
like our the evil is an eclipsing not
actually tangible force not a real thing
and so is it possible for someone
without Christ to somehow come into
touch deeply with logos within them
therefore with Christ um
I think the argument would be ultimately
yes the best means would be to to hear
the gospel proclaimed Jesus Christ is
Lord and to respond to that in faith as
you know the the New Testament talks
about but even apart from that everyone
already has Locos and therefore everyone
already has that pattern etched into
their very existence and so that's how
we could possibly see the capacity
outside of the sacramental boundaries of
the church people were coming to a
position of you know harmony with their
with their being one of the early church
fathers uh St Justin Martyr refers to uh
and it picks up actually this is a
presocratic idea the the logos
spermaticus the seeds of the word which
are all through creation and so this is
the fundamental essence of of all of
reality not only in us but in all of
creation and so I he was dealing with
the fact that people were pointing out
well how come there's dying and Rising
gods in all sorts of different cultures
how come all of the things that you find
in the the Christian faith are already
present in many myths and and cultures
and so forth and he said that's
brilliant you know of course they are
this is true if it wasn't true it
wouldn't be so and so in that sense
absolutely what we are trying to do as
Orthodox Christians is simply live in
complete harmony with who we are as
human beings this isn't an outside
imposition this is the very core of what
we are this is the Fulfillment and
trajectory of creation and so that's why
you know coming back to the earlier
point about you how can we have this
dialogue this engagement with the world
with social sciences with physical
sciences with app you know pure physics
and Mathematics we can do that because
it all ties in anyway we we are hoping
as Orthodox Christians we are in touch
with what is fundamentally true of
creation and of our own human personhood
so hopefully that would you
thank you for that to
um well I suppose Dr Peterson would be
best equipped to handle this uh are or
or anyone are Yan archetypes in accord
with or opposed to Orthodox theology I
don't know too much about what that
means but maybe you
do
well the problem with answering out for
me is that I'm by no means an expert on
Orthodox theology so um but what from
what I understand of it I would
say y y believed that Yung was a student
of
nature it's something that isn't well
known about Yung because most of the
history of psychoanalytic thought was
written by the freudians and they think
of Yung as a student of Freud and of
course that's true Yung was really
introduced to the idea a profound idea
of the unconscious through Freud and
also at least in part to the idea that
there was an interior world of
symbols but at the same time Yung was a
student of N and you see n announced the
death of God in the late 1900s and what
he meant by that in some sense was
that he meant that the spirit of truth
that had been instantiated by
Christianity had turned against the the
dogma of Christianity and destroyed it
and what he meant by that was that the
emerging the the the the emergence of
Science in the context of Western
culture and the elaborate description of
physical reality that that was developed
as a consequence ended up in apparent
contradiction with the truths of with
the truths of of our religious tradition
and we pick the most developed truth and
let the other one go and nature was
not celebrating that contrary to what
most people think I mean when he spoke
of the death of God he said that it was
an absolute catastrophe and that we
would pay for it with millions of lives
and that was his prognostication for the
20th century which happened to come true
in precisely the manner he indicated for
exactly the
reasons n believed that we would have to
invent our own values because we had
become because the old values that we
had lived by had had bled themselves out
and died but the problem with that and
this is something Yung picked up on the
problem with that is that you can't
invent your own values and you know that
because all of you have tried on New
Year's Day to decide that you're going
to eat less and go to the gym and you'd
think if you could create your own
values you know being this sort of
demigod that as soon as you told
yourself that you would eat properly and
go to the gym you be up at 6:00 in the
morning you know eating carrots and
rotab bagas and then going off to lift
heavy weights and of course you're not
you're sitting in your chair at night
eating Cheetos and and watching watching
pornography you
know so how in the world is something
like that supposed to create its own
values you're you're not in control of
yourself to that degree and so yung's
answer to that problem was to was
essentially to to look partly within and
partly to look in the symbolic domain
and what he realized as a consequence of
doing that was that there was a profound
answer to the question of the
resurrection of value and for him that
was really the embodiment of the pattern
of of Christ that was the self as far as
Yung was concerned there's no difference
between the the archetypal self and the
symbolic Christ they were the same thing
as far as Yung was concerned in so far
as Christ is the vision of the perfect
man right which is a symbolic Vision so
you could say well what is Christ and
the answer to that is well Christ is
whatever you think of as the perfect man
now you're going to have diverse
representations of that so you could
think about it Christ as the totality of
the visions of the perfect man it's
something like that and then that the
goal of life was to embody that as
deeply as possible and Yung also
believed that the world would transform
itself around you to the degree that you
did that to a to a to an
unspecifiable degree and that's where
the the symbolic reality and the
historical reality unite you know and
because and and we know it's true we
also know this is true if you look at
people like gandi or you look at people
like Soulja niton for example these are
great people who stood up as moral icons
let's say in the midst of absolute chaos
and they transformed entire
civilizations by doing that by standing
up for what they believe to be true true
they transformed the entire world around
them and of course they're only
partially perfect someone like Soulja
niton or someone like Gandhi or or
perhaps someone like Nelson Mandela
they're only partial incarnations of
perfection but even to the degree that
they were flawed know they were perfect
enough so that despite their Remnant
flaws they were able to reorganize being
itself around them and we don't know
what the ultimate limit of that is we
really don't it could be that everything
will deline itself around people to the
degree that they put themselves together
and I actually I've had experiences that
make me convinced that that's the case I
I truly believe that that's the case so
and that's also what gives me some some
belief in these strange Christian ideas
about the harrowing of hell and the
overcoming of death it's like we have no
idea what we could do as individual
embodiments of the logos which is
clearly what we are because we're all
conscious we have no idea what obstacles
we could overcome and what what massive
Transformations we could undertake if we
actually lived Our Lives properly God
only knows what we could get rid of we
could get rid of malaria we could get
schistosomiasis and the guinea worm
those are going to be gone soon anyways
polio we're going to get rid of hunger
maybe we can get rid of death maybe we
can get rid of Hell who knows and I know
I'm certainly someone who believes that
hell is real because I've read enough of
the accounts of what happened in the
20th century to know precisely that it's
as real as the most warped imagination
can possibly make and that's plenty real
enough for me
so well so I would say yung's vision is
very much in keeping as far as I can
understand with the central traditions
of the Orthodox church because he
believed that it was the highest moral
duty of the of the awake soul to
participate in manifestation of the self
that's and that's this Union of things
that that Jonathan talked about that's
beyond Duality it's it's to bring
everything in you together into this
kind of of Harmony that then extends
Beyond you into your family and and past
that it's musical that's what music
represents that's why we find it so
intensely meaningful that's what music
tells us it's a it's a it's an artwork
based upon the meaning of pattern and it
and it infuses everyone you know what
it's like to listen to music even the
darkest Punk rocking Anarchist atheist
is overwhelmed with the glory of God
when he listens to his punk rock music
so
yeah just a quick comment on that um
going back to the the central part of
that question which is about archetypes
and whether they're the same same thing
I would largely agree with that point uh
to the extent to which anyone is in
touch with the logos within them they
are going to be in touch with
fundamental archetypes and those would
be the same that the the church fathers
refer us to and so forth for the one
element that and this kind of relates to
the previous question about can you do
this without Christ the thing which is
the possibly the unique element of
Christian uh
Faith it's not love so often people
think love is what defines Christianity
in fact love can be found throughout the
world it's more hope and what I know
about Yung which isn't all that much but
absolutely the archetypes are there
would go with that does he come with the
same level of hope that we would as
Orthodox I don't know I mean sometimes
you wonder whether the kavis the The
Descent kind of leads us to a hell where
we inhabit without hope and rather with
despair coming back to that point about
AR Commander
sopon put your mind in hell but don't
despair in other words have hope so is
it possible to have that hope without
ultimately what we have which is the
cross and the message of the Cross as an
archetype is that we stare into the
depths of darkness and death and we
Proclaim light and life in
fact you know that's what Jesus himself
says when he refers us back to the Old
Testament to when the people of Israel
were dying in the wilderness having come
out with Moses and they're grumbling
because they said we if only we were
back in Egypt where we had it so good
course the reality of Egypt was slavery
but they thought no no we're just going
to Grumble and they're afflicted by
serpents and and God says this most
incredible thing put a serpent on a
stick and hold it up and those people
that look at the serpent look at the
source of the suffering and death will
be healed and so Christ says Jesus says
the son of man will be raised up so we
have to look upon death and suffering we
have to descend into hell but with with
life with light the the light that that
is never extinguished to come back to
the prologue of St John I don't know
whether that's there in Yung and I can
be corrected on that but that's possibly
the point where you know a purely social
science or psychological approach might
be lacking because I say the Christian
virtue par excellance is Hope because
it's it's almost unique in its capacity
to look into everything that is so dark
and say there is yet life there is yet
light
so one of the things that really
affected Yung who who by the way worked
for the American government and the CIA
during World War II um sending them
psychological reports on Hitler um
Yung meditated for a very long period of
time on what happened in Nazi Germany
and yung's the dictum that he derived
from his chemical studies was inquilinus
inventure which I'm probably saying
wrong but it means the thing you want
most will be will be found the place you
least want to look and so for you
because one of the questions you might
ask yourself is that if Enlightenment is
possible let's say if Union with the
self is possible or some sort of
mystical Transcendence why in the world
aren't we just all that way what what's
the barrier it's like well we could be
way better well why not just do it then
if it's just right there ahead of us but
but the answer to to that is is I is
something like you cannot conceive of
how good a human being might be until
you can conceive of how evil a human
being can and will be and that means to
encounter in yourself the Nazi that the
prison guard the osz guard to understand
fully that there is no difference
between you and the people who were
killing children in the Nazi death camps
that's you and that's that encounter
with hell that's literally that
encounter with hell you're a Denison of
Hell in so far as you're capable of that
and you are capable of that and there
isn't anything I think that can scare
you
straight except that knowledge you can
be you can be and are a a a vessel that
can be used for absolute evil and you
would participate in it you would
participate in it and so for Yung the
pathway to it's like Dante don't get to
Paradise before you go to the lowest
levels of hell right right at the bottom
where betrayal lurks for Dante that was
the worst of all sins and so it's a
terrifying process I try to teach my
students one in my maps of meaning class
which is the opposite of a safe space as
far as I'm concerned I and I mean that
technically I truly do mean that I try
to convince my students I try to get
them to meditate on the fact that
they're the damn Nazis really because
what is it it's what is it the Germans
like come on really no obviously not
it's people and so the pathway to
Paradise is through hell and that's it's
no wonder no one goes there I mean who
wants to go there no one well if you
don't go there voluntarily you'll go
there accidentally so it's better to go
there voluntarily because then you can
go with hope you can say I can withstand
this maybe I can find a light at the end
of the tunnel
a question for Mr P uh you have spoken
in the past about the supposedly
contradictory nature of symbols for
example water uh represents both healing
and dangerous chaos can you speak about
how we can resolve this apparent
contradiction and to follow up how does
this apply to the relationship between
the internal mental world and the
external material world
you might have to repeat the second part
of that question after I answer the
first part
um um I think I mean I I've been one of
the things as as you said that I've been
thinking a lot about is the is the
duality of of symbols um every every
image every symbol has like a dark and a
and a light light side and you can see
it when you read the Bible when you you
read the stories or even when you look
at icons or when you look at images and
um the um it has to do with with with
this idea of a of ascent or this idea of
moving up because
um what's important when we are on the
spiritual journey is the direction that
we're facing it's it's not so much where
we are like if you can imagine the
ascent of the world world or of
ourselves up to God as a ladder which is
how often it's represented in in in
Orthodox icons as this ladder that we
Ascend towards god um you could be
pretty high up the ladder but if you
fall there's no point right the the idea
is to ascend and so all the symbols that
we see in
um in the Bible have those two sides and
and water is a is a perfect example in
the Old Testament all through the old
test Old Testament
water is an image of death um the flood
um and then the crossing of the Red Sea
you know the crossing of the Jordan it
is constantly the symbol of death
but the key to resolving the uh duality
of symbolism is Christ he is always the
key to all the stories I believe and so
when you look at the story of Christ and
you see how he takes the say the dark
side of a symbol and he flips it over
and then makes it into something else so
that's like the mystery let's say of
baptism you know why why would we have
to be baptized I mean it's very strange
that this flood you know this Red Sea
that the Egyptians were drowned in why
would we have to be baptized well it's
because the Christ takes this death and
changes into changes it into a process
of let's say washing or a process C of
purification and so the same symbol
which is which is death can also be a
symbol of
washing so so so it's the same with fire
fire is the perfect example I mean when
you look at icons you'll see fire in
hell and you'll see fire coming from the
sky as the manifestation of the holy
spirit so what does that mean um and so
it's the same thing let's say You You
You See Fire as division well there's a
negative division which is the division
in which we scatter ourselves and we're
and we're we're consumed but there's
another type of division let's say the
division of Pentecost which is the
division which embodies the multiplicity
of how God manifests himself in the
world and so it just depends on which
side you take each symbol so I hope that
answers that question what was the
second part
again something about the inside follow
up how does this apply to the
relationship between the internal m al
world and the external Material
World okay yeah I think I understand I
think I understand what that what that
means
um I think it well it is my real my
belief that symbolism Is Anchored In
experience and I don't think that most
symbols are not just these abstract
things that that float above us so for
example um a good example would be for
example the mountain we see in the Old
Testament we have the this sense that
Moses ascends the mountain and then
encounters God and then we see it
repeated over and over in in the
patterns of the stories where Christ
ascends a hill or ascends a mountain and
then something happens there's a
revelation on on this mountain and you
think like well that's strange right I
mean why would you want what what does a
mountain have to do with anything um so
I think the key is to understanding a
lot of symbolism is to kind of see it as
as an and this is an experience and so
if you ask yourself for example what
happens when I go up a mountain just
physically what happens well as you go
up a
mountain you the the the base of the
mountain which is the large this huge
thing starts to refine itself and then
it starts to become smaller and smaller
and smaller and that up to you get to
the point and then everything is is
one and then if you stand at the top of
a mountain and you look around when
you're at the bottom of the mountain all
you can see is the trees and that are
right next to you and you can see a very
particular part of the world but if you
ascend to the top of a mountain then you
have this vision of
everything um and so the symbolism of
the mountain which is found in the Bible
in the gospel in the icons is akin to
the the the the
phenomenological reality of that thing
so we often it's difficult for us to get
that because we're so caught up in a
scientific vision of the world that it's
difficult to understand the symbolism
but if you if you just put yourself in
the position of someone who does
something or someone like water is the
same I mean water what do we do with
water we wash ourselves with water and
what is washing washing is removing all
the external and dead things that we
have on our hands so that we're purified
well that's that's one of the symb
that's one of the the symbols of baptism
so yeah so I think I hope that explains
that
question this question isn't addressed
to anyone in particular so anyone
willing to answer can do so
um I'd like to hear your thoughts on the
concept of Free Will as many as many of
Mo of the modern atheists believe that
Free Will is an
illusion uh according to their belief in
material in materialism how does one
reconcile Free Will with an omniscient
God who knows the end from the beginning
who knows your future and created you
such that you were compelled to realize
it so believe it or not we get this
question all the
time we get this question from teens
believe it or not this uh it's it's it's
the perennial question you know um
if God knows what's going to happen
because he does if he if God is
everywhere and fills all things he is
past present and future then how can you
have free will and then of course all
those other implications right so you
know if if I don't have free will or if
God knows what I'm going to do in the
end then then does he create some people
to to go to hell or to be away from him
or to not you know reach Union with him
and others and if so then how can he be
Lov and all these other things so um I
think the the fundamental um
misunderstanding
is I I would say the concept of time of
creation itself so the idea that God um
we think as human beings in a linear way
right we have no other way of thinking
so we have a beginning we have a present
and then we have an end and this is the
way the world works it moves in One
Direction um we have no concept of of
God's reality and the idea of being
outside of time we have no concept to
that we wouldn't even know how to begin
to think about that if if we tried and
people have tried um the easiest um
analogy I guess or example that I could
I could give would be um the idea of
perspective and what do I mean by that
um let's
say I'm the camera person here right and
I'm watching this kind of whole event
unfolding um after it's happened so it's
it's been video vide taped right and
somebody else can watch this and they
can watch this event and they can
forward they can go back and they can go
back to see something that they really
liked or something that they forgot or
they can fast forward to the end and and
see how it all turned out um the person
who is watching that who is removed from
that reality uh they can see what's
going on and what's not going on they
can jump ahead in the past but they
don't cause it uh it's just their
perspective is different so this idea
and of course this is kind of a crude
analogy um of course it's much more
compli comp Lex than that it's much more
nuanced than that and uh and and of
course we would we would believe least
as Orthodox Christians that God is is is
much more um permeates all things and is
working in people's lives um but there
is a strange Paradox between free will
the idea that we have the choice uh
whether we want to um follow God to
believe in him uh or to believe rather
than ourselves and I think as Professor
Peterson said you know the reality of
the hell that many of us live in and the
reality of the hell that has been
created by societies and civilizations
all over the world is a proof of the
reality of free will it's proof um at
least for people who believe in God now
if you don't believe in God it's a
different story then you would say well
that's not a proof of anything except
that we're just we're just animals
living on this planet and there's no
meaning to anything but if there's a God
and there are still horrible things
happening well either that God is is you
know an evil being or rather rather that
we have the free will not to believe in
him not to follow him not to do his will
um and and and that may seem like a
horrible horrible thing for God to give
to us you know this idea of Free Will um
and yet it is also the greatest thing
the greatest thing because it's not only
the idea of us avoiding suffering or us
avoiding sin or us avoiding the evil
that we create within the world but it
is the idea of the you the idea that
through our own sin and through our own
difficulties we somehow Find meaning and
we and we we come up on the other side
so
um I I I don't know how how much better
I can I can try to explain it it's a
it's a complex thing
but so in the mythological world I would
say there are three continually
intertwined causal
elements one of one is cons ious you
could say that's the logos one is the
interpretive structure within which that
logos exists and that's the framework
that you use to organize yourself
cognitively within the world your point
of view and then there's the world
itself the natural world let's say those
three things are always in interplay and
they're each given causal Primacy um you
see this echoed in popular culture
motifs and I think Pinocchio is a very
good example of that where Pinocchio has
a father and and that's jepetto who's
his creator and he's a puppet so a very
deterministic sort of creature and he
has a mother and that's the Blue Fairy
that comes down from heaven who's really
a a figure of the Vitality of Nature and
so Pinocchio is portrayed in the movie
as child of Nature and culture which is
of course how we're portrayed
scientifically but but there's a third
element in that movie which is really
what drives the plot forward which is
Pinocchio's capacity to make make
choices and that's his Consciousness and
that's also what elevates him above the
status of deterministic puppet now you
might say well there's no evidence that
we're not deterministic and I could say
well that's fine because there's also no
evidence that we are deterministic so we
can leave that as a draw but we
certainly treat each other as if we have
free will we treat ourselves as if we
have free will we even those of us who
regard each other as deterministic
believe that or as determined believe
that in their own actions they're going
to be perfectly irritated at whatever
choices you make that happen to infringe
upon them and they're going to act
towards you as if you're an agent with
free will so they can say they regard
people as deterministic but they don't
act it out so I don't believe that they
believe it and I also don't believe that
you can produce a functional Society
without having something like that at
its basis and I've never seen any
evidence of a functional Society being
produced with that without that as a
metaphysical
presupposition so but there's something
more crucially crucial involved here too
is
that in order to accept the
inevitability of determinism in Human
Action you have to accept the
presupposition that Consciousness is
nothing but an epiphenomena of a deeper
material reality and first of all we do
not know that we certainly do not know
that what we know about Consciousness
scientifically you could put in a
thimble and still have enough room for
another thimble we know nothing about it
it's a mystery have not cracked at all
and people have been beadling away
pretty hard on it from a scientific
perspective for the last 40 years since
it's become in Vogue again and I don't
think we've moved forward a little bit
and then finally so it's a mystery and
and and I I don't think there's any
evidence whatsoever that it isn't I read
Dan dennett's bit book on explaining
Consciousness and it does nothing of the
sort it explains it away and that's that
and many critics have made the same
comment but I also think that
phenomenologically speaking it is the
case that we seem to encounter the world
as a field of possibility from which we
extract out choices you know you think
well when I talk to you about your
future I mean you know what your future
is it's a branching set of Pathways
which you can Envision because you you
can Envision the future it's one of the
very strange things about being human
it's a branching set of Pathways of
possibilities and you can pick from
among them and I do believe that's what
you're doing is do believe that the
world is a well of possibility and
potential and that you interact with it
by choice and transform it it within
your limited power into what you want it
to be
and and I don't think there's any
evidence to the contrary and besides
determinism is a is a scientific
philosophy that probably lost its Vogue
in about
1850 so you
know there's no there's just no reason
to from a scientific perspective to
describe human beings as deterministic
creatures there's no evidence for it so
we're partly determined obviously
because there's lots of things we can't
do but that does not by any stretch of
the imagination mean we're fully
determined
so can I just add to that that I mean
first of all that's a thoroughly
Orthodox answer I have to say um we only
can deal with what we have in front of
us I mean picking up on Jonathan's Point
earlier about experience and our our own
going forth what the church fathers tell
us I mean contrary to this you know
scientific notion of you know the time
moving forward at a kind of regular rate
or anything that we might have conceived
in our minds that actually each
infinitesimally small moment of our
existence is pregnant with infinite
possibility and so it's precisely what
has just been said that we have that
within our grasp if only we have the
eyes to see it if only we have the
hearts and Minds oriented to that the
logos guiding us then I mean the church
fathers talk about the fact that we can
actually
experience
Infinity in the tiniest of moments
that's what theosis is all about that's
what coming into contact with uncreated
energies is all about in the in the
Eastern spiritual tradition that I mean
time and space are elastic we knew that
before Einstein ever even was born and
that's what we have in front of us so
let's not get into philosophical
arguments about how God works and how he
sees is precisely father Ted's point I
mean that's irrelevant what we know is
that every tiny tiny moment of every day
and every space of this
macrocosmos is the possibility of
encountering the infinite and that
that's what we have to reach forward and
graas and that's what our whole
tradition is about and so absolutely is
is our position on on that point so we
don't get into debates about you know
predestination and and and not it's
irrelevant to us we just need to grab
hold of God where he is which is right
now in this moment in this space as we
are thank you very much father and thank
you very much to each and every one of
our panelists uh could I just get a
round of applause for all of
you
[Applause]
and with that I'd like to conclude this
night thank you to absolutely everyone
for coming I hope we've managed to learn
a lot this has been recorded so just in
case this was too much information to
take in which is certainly was for me it
will be available at some point or
another another so once again thank you
all for coming out